mv bentornati sul canale rito stories
allora oggi andremo a fare lo slime
trasparente che sembra atto allo avrete
visto su instagram bielo visto ovunque
su internet in pratica imbergano la mano
sembra di immergere la mano nell'acqua e
invece è uno slime super super di cicli
e ho fatto già una slide simile nel mio
video precedente per questa volta stava
diverso perché sarà un po più
trasparente esso poco 0 una tecnica
diversa
quindi invece di far gol ha permesso
questo tutorial da un canale thailandese
e poi vi lascio il nome in descrizione
come quello ho lasciato anche nell'altro
video allora stanno super curioso di
vedere come riuscirà mi avete chiesto in
tantissimi come fare questo tipo di
stent è semplicissimo da fare e
soprattutto e senza colla incredibile ma
vero e senza colla quindi mi raccomando
se volete vedere altre ricette di stress
senza colla lasciate un bel laica 10.000
likes andrò a fare altre ricette
esclusive di stelle senza colla
mettetevi le cuffie perché ci saranno
anche pari fonia smr supererà santi e
vediamo se riuscite a trovare la parola
segreta del giorno che è tornata quindi
è soprattutto questo tipo di slime è un
po particolare se invece da fare ma in
particolare quindi dovete seguire bene
le istruzioni se volete che vi riesca
bene siete prodi 321 via come per
l'altro slime vi serve semplicemente un
po d'acqua
io però questa volta ho usato
semplicemente 500 ml di acqua quindi
mezzo litro invece avete visto che
nell'altro slam in usato molte di più ho
usato un litro e mezzo le quantità erano
diverse infatti uscito molto meno
trasparente rispetto a questo quindi se
volete seguire la ricetta posto per
passo usate mezzo litro d'acqua poi il
secondo ingrediente come nell'altro
slime fatto vedere poi lo swing va giù è
la guerre gum
io l'ho trovata su amazon vi lascio il
link
diamo azzurro di questo prodotto in
descrizione nella descrizione del video
e alla fine non dovete usarne tanta
quindi potete fare un bel po di slime
dalla da una bustina di guarda quindi
diciamo che conviene abbastanza allora
in questo caso ho usato mi sembra che
qua mettevo mentre cucchiaino mezzo
cucchiaino prima in pratica dovette
metterne poca e poi rischiare poi
aggiungerne un altro po e poi mischiare
per evitare di fare troppi i grumi
anche se poi andremo a scolarla poi vi
faccio vedere questa volta non usa lo
scolapasta
ho preso losco lino comunque mette un
altro mezzo cucchiaino sempre di guarda
un eco un altro metodo per farlo ancora
più chiaro per farlo uscire ancora più
chiaro questo slime è di setacciare
anche il guardian così vedete crea
ancora meno grumi mescolate il tutto e
se vedete che si sono ancora un bel po
di grumi come qualche comunque ce ne
sono meno rispetto all'altro estremo che
avevo fatto però a eccone aggiunto
ancora un pochino perché non mi sembrava
molto densa la consistenza però
attenzione più guardan
aggiungete più opaco sarà lo slime poi
ne serve comunque un po per addentarlo
ho provato a mettere pochissimo bergamo
per farlo super trasparente però non si
addensava quindi insomma almeno un paio
di cucchiaini ci vogliono
allora ho continuato mescolarlo però
vedete che ci sono ancora un bel po di
ruby allora dovete semplicemente
travasarlo e poi appunto utilizzare il
colino così tiene tutti i grumi
fatemi sapere nei commenti se preferite
i video con solo con questa inquadratura
quindi dall'alto oppure con due
inquadrature come nell'altro video slime
se l'avete visto mi in quadro sia io che
l'inquadratura dall'alto la mettono lo
stesso schermo quindi fatemelo sapere
ora nei commenti
allora dopo che avete
travasato del tutto vedrete che i grumi
rimangono sopra vi rimarrà insomma un
composto più pulito e liscio sotto sta
usando il colorante questa volta sta
usando quello blu proprio perché voglio
che esca una sorta di acqua tipo acqua e
notare notare come sto attento a non
macchiarmi anche se poi non avete visto
i retroscena in realtà mi sono macchiata
di poe cinque volte va bene sono perdere
il dito macchiato ancora poi per
attivarlo sto usando la soluzione per
lenti il bicarbonato allora ho provato
anche usando il laboratory sciolta
nell'acqua calda ma non ha funzionato
anche creato un gruppo un po brutto io
veramente ho un bruttissimo rapporto
collaborato perché ogni volta non
riescono bene quando questo campo razze
invece preferisco usare la soluzione per
lenti quindi non mi è uscito molto bene
se voi lo fate con la bora cioè fatemelo
sapere nei commenti si è riuscito bene
allora sto aggiungendo un altro po di
blu perché come potete vedere è
diventato una sorta di verde acqua
quindi non è proprio azzurro poi ai
inizialmente dovete mischiarlo un po
lentamente per non creare troppo molle
poi queste mischiarlo più velocemente
guardate che bel colore mi sono
innamorata di questo colore sembra il
colore della soris family quindi del
nostro logo o agendo un altro po di
bicarbonato perché non si stava pensando
molto comunque consiglio con questo
slime non vi scoraggiate se vedete che
rimane il liquido perché si vuole un bel
po di tempo prima che si addensi io
ovviamente non ha filmato tutto il
processo mentre il tila tequila wojtyla
ma se non sarebbe stato troppo lungo
però ci vuole un bel po di tempo prima
che si addensi e a un certo punto
penserete che ancora non si è addensato
una realtà si è addensato perché rimane
super liquido e sembra davvero acqua
quando lo toccate sembra di toccare
l'acqua è fantastico è davvero uno slam
unico nel suo genere
poi se volete che diventi ancora più
trasparente dovete lasciarlo a riposare
tra l'altro sentite che suoni che fa
pazzeschi super smr soprattutto se vi
piacciono i suoni acquatici sono
meravigliosi
allora io l'ho lasciato a riposare e
realtà non so se ci voglia un coperchio
no io ho appoggiato questo più grande
perché era l'unico che avevo e ho
aspettato un paio d ore se non sbaglio e
questo è il risultato
mi sono innamorato di questo slime adoro
il colore è davvero stupendo questo
azzurro celeste chiaro uno dei miei
colori preferiti e ora smetto di parlare
perché se non nei commenti come sempre
milite parli troppo comunque allora
questo qua è il risultato mi posso
sentire un po di suoni me lo posso anche
vedere bene è fantastico e super
rilassante giocarci e come vi ho detto
prima sembra di giocare con l'acqua è
infatti la parola segreta del giorno è
slime line dal colore stupendo sì perché
no se avete visto il video fino ad ora
scrivete nei commenti slime dal colore
stupendo e scrivetemi anche nei commenti
quale colore volete che usi nel mio
prossimo video live e ora vi lascio con
un po di relax
perché ora ci saranno dei suoni
fantastici super rilassanti
a
[Applauso]
allora aspetto di leggere i commenti le
vostre opinioni su questo slime secondo
me è meraviglioso fatemi sapere se vi
piace che colore vi piacerebbe vedere
nel prossimo slime e se vi piacciono
questi strani lasciate pure un like se
volete vedere altre ricette esclusive di
slam senza colla vediamo essere aggiunti
10 mila likes e io vi lascio fa altri
video da vedere e vi mando un bacione
enorme alla festiva